why are you gonna love america what do i
love what is america to love today
what what what is it when you ask
somebody like i asked a question do you
love america
you ask a regular person like you know
what how you do not go in the streets
mm-hmm you know what
i shouldn't do that you know what you
should do about it i want you to do that
i will i want you to go and say
do you love america and let them say set
it up okay you guys going to miami
do you love america and they say what
yes or no no matter what they say guess
what the next question is
why yeah okay no i hate america why
i love america why do you see who's
traveled and who hasn't yeah
i'll tell you anthony bourdain you know
had a great great quote and said like
to to know america is to love her and
it's the truth man like
we've all traveled we've all been very
lucky to have traveled this whole
country and there's no way that you can
travel this country
and just not be like man this is a great
place this is a great place full of
great people and it's not perfect but
it's great
and it's trying to be better and we're
going through growing pains and that's
why i probably you know i hate the
commies more than anything else because
you know especially the upper middle
class commies like it's not perfect burn
it down and it's like bro we're doing
pretty good here
we're not perfect but we're trying and
every every
person you meet almost every person
outside of an incredibly small
outlier wants them and their neighbors
and their neighbors families to be
successful
and one of the great things about covid
that never gets talked about is every
single person
with no questions asked really almost
almost every
human being was willing to shut down
their business was willing to shutter
themselves in their house
was willing to shut down their lives
completely because they thought it would
make their community safer
now as time rolled on and it was six
months eight months ten months and there
was a ton of mixed messages and then we
realized okay there's there's political
motivations behind this
you started getting serious pushback as
you should have i was ready to throw the
tea in the harbor and
i was waiting for the booga boys to come
with me but
the in the beginning every single one of
us
really showed our love for country and
nation i believe that we showed our love
for community first few months
because we shut it down because we we
wanted to keep each other six weeks guys
six weeks yeah yeah yeah
15 days to flatten the curve right so
part of this anxiety that i feel and
that a lot of people feel
is we were lied to now
i feel like i love the country i hate
our
government and i'm able to make those
two that i'm able to distinguish between
the two
i hate our federal government with every
fiber of my being i hate our federal
government but i love the people of the
united states of america explain the two
so so explain what part of the
government you hate i hate the federal
government
i hate what our federal government has
become i hate the the
the uh the panopticon that we're living
in i hate the
the the security state that we've given
our lives to i think
uh you know people have been saying this
for 20 years
and they've been wait we've been waiting
and waiting we are seeing
the ramifications of the patriot act we
are seeing today we are living
in the fallout from the patriot act we
are living in the fallout from bush
cheney rumsfeld
and the the the way that our life is
being infringed upon
and now the the the elites the
quote-unquote elites they are saying
the quiet parts out loud and this ivy
league cabal
of you know the entrenched powers that
are always going to be in power
um you know the fact that that they're
so beholden they look
i said it and i've said it before and
and maybe it sounds salacious but this
is the truth and i believe it to be the
truth
they had a chance to choose between the
united states and china and they chose
china
and that's just the truth of it they did
not choose us they have not chose their
citizens
they have not chose the the people down
here at the ground floor you saw it in
washington
dc over the weekend when they erased
cuba libre off the street
they erased it off the street these are
people fighting tyranny
real tyranny real tyranny and they
erased it off the street because it was
going to
incite hatred but any any communist fist
whether it's black lives matter or not
forget the black lives matter it's the
communist fist
that kami fist is gonna stay on the dc
streets forever
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye